we're back with a worth it season six
six new episodes we're gonna be doing
some new things seeing some old friends
visiting some historic sites making some
new friends and we're going to a few of
our personal favorite restaurants yeah
we're starting off with one of our most
requested foods or Rito's I didn't
surprise it how long we've been doing
this
speaking of long things the last burrito
in this video crazy today I'm worth it
we're going to be trying three different
burritos at three drastically different
price points to find out which one is
the most worth it at is price today
we're going to what is honestly one of
my favorite restaurants it's called
Sonora town we're gonna be chatting with
tio and Jennifer and we're going there
to try their chimichanga if there's one
place I'm gonna rave about it's gonna be
soon we're down there my number one rave
I cannot imagine a better rate I don't
want to them it actually I do want to
imagine you at a rave did you imagine me
on ecstasy are we going there right now
you're about to see we have this burrito
tell us about Sonora town we're in
northern Mexican style buck idiot based
on Tio's hometown of Sunday's Rio
corrado Mexico northern Mexico all
cooked over mesquite the grill was
really the main reason why we opened the
restaurant that's really the secret
ingredient so the outside of the
tortilla has almost a perfume to it that
adds as much the flavor is what you're
getting inside the tortilla Senora and
South tortillas should be very thin
delicate almost like a bedsheet we get
our flour from sonora mexico we've tried
different ones from here it doesn't work
out that trips to Sonoma is five hours
by car twice per month we drive to Tio's
hometown we buy sacks of flour and we
cross that as many times as we can
before it's time to come home Wow yeah
and then if we're crossing like giant
sacks of like white powder
I noticed you also have a bean and
cheese burrito on your menu yeah we both
love bean cheese burritos it's a great
way to taste the tortilla so really
simple beans cheese and our red salsa my
mom she was a field worker she would
make them for herself go to work and eat
a couple of them but then come back with
a few my sisters would fight over you
and cheese burritos and just like we
think it seriously yeah I know that we
came here primarily for the chimichanga
but it's recommended that we tried the
bean and cheese burrito how can we not I
begin mmm oh my god mr. tortilla is
insane Wow it's like flaky but not
flaking all I did in life being cheese
who's the bean is a cheesy
who's the bean who's the cheese 1 2 3
jeez yeah and I'm gonna be Adams a
tortilla
I'm not saving any for Adam sorry they
are yeah you can just have it thank you
I had never heard of a chimichanga
before Sonora town what is it Jimmy
chunga what makes it a chimichanga is
the filling a burrito with a Gustavo
inside like a stew - red of beef grilled
tomatoes grilled Anaheim chilies cheeses
spices to be charged oh yeah oh oh it's
warm
I mean Asti here cheers Cheers is that
the best thing you ever had it might be
it's up there am i right that's great
oh now we're gonna try it with the
special salsa chip the beans are needed
basically just sonoda kind of citrusy of
a clean bite let's kick it up a notch
Oh Oh sweetness in the mouth and then
I'll kick in the throat that's very
tasty I don't want it to go away
what did your mom think about this she
was making these for you as a kid and
now it's like you've turned into a
really successful business in LA she
wants royalties if they sold tortillas I
would straight up just by tortillas from
them you should just buy burritos and
then just unwrap them and keep it
tortillas that's actually a stupid idea
that I love thank you thank you very
much okay I know what we're doing next
we're gonna get some Pendleton so to
continue with our Sonora theme we're
gonna check out this bakery called
Sonora bakery yeah I'm ready for some
more Sonora low
mmm papaya and dulce de leche mmm
ready for it burrito fat burrito facts
burritos or a regular meal for
astronauts in space since tortillas
don't create crumbs in the same way the
sandwich bread too often does Wow good
enough for NASA good enough for me
oh this is really soft oh goodness and
we got a cinnamon roll for Adam
[Music]
okay so that does it for today our next
one is a breakfast burrito
so you complete everybody here sleep and
what thank you for the instruction to
sleep at night tomorrow morning we're
starting off with a breakfast burrito at
a place called loci where the owner matt
is showing us his cheese crusted
breakfast burrito did you hear those
words yet I just uttered she's crusted
burrito okay
[Music]
what is Loki burritos so it's just a
pop-up breakfast burrito I was working
at breakfast burrito joint I kept
getting in trouble for doing things like
my own way I had one kid had a second
kid on the way and I was like I can't do
this anymore I turned 25 I heard this
superstition that 25 could be your best
or worst year so I'm like screw it let's
jump off the cliff - yeah it's pretty
easy to do something with quality and a
little bit effort so why not do it were
you surprised by the popularity I told
myself when I first started I'm gonna
give this six months and it'd better be
popular I'm wasting my time and I just
kept saying that every day six months
from now
et la came out like six months after
that yeah and then it got really popular
I usually start serving right at 7:15
and then I don't have any time after
that
your burrito has a cheese crust can you
tell us about that so my friend sells
hot dogs at the farmers market you know
selling breakfast burritos on the
streets so he was like hey man let me
make you my off-menu breakfast burrito
then he put cheese on the ground like
dude what he doing he got like the big
old press and he was pushing on it I'm
like dude this is delicious I'm totally
gonna steal that from you and he's like
yeah man this is how you do it he was
into the idea of you taking that and
running with it yeah he said this is how
you do it easy as that now that I've
made the cheese crust burrito I don't
really like it without cheese crust
we're in the parking lot Matt is still
over there there's a group of men in
brown overalls that's how you know a
food vendor is good when men and
overalls are eating there all right do
that so warm instantly the smell of
cheese this is wild
there's something about griddled cheese
that has a very she's it smell cheers to
you it is a crust it's not overly cheesy
here's the thing you go into work you
don't want to be like putting stuff I'm
actually very happy how surprisingly
light this burrito is yeah it's really
not greasy at all so I just realized
something
it's a breakfast burrito uh-huh and what
it is did you realize why they call it a
breakfast burrito it's not just eaten
during breakfast it's a breakfast
packaged in a burrito
yeah it's breakfast foods Annie's
looking at me like I'm crazy sometimes
okay sometimes we will see the tree
before the forest I see the four through
the trees I don't know if you noticed
but on the menu they actually have a
huambo size where that mean it's a lot
bigger adamant annie are gonna have a
Huambo size
Oh
low-key burrito great started my morning
right into food coma a little bit but
it's perfect because we have a three and
a half hour road trip right now to the
middle of California there were road
trippin to Fresno road trip what gets
quite hot there so to beat the heat
we're going to see the fourth year
underground gardens it's a hundred
degrees right now in Fresno so we're now
a little bit further underground it's a
little bit cooler here right this is the
underground Garden of Sicilian immigrant
Baldassare full this year he was a
citrus farmer who moved to Fresno
planning to farm citrus but he
discovered all this hard rock and made
it impossible to do the farming that he
wanted to do he decided to build this
underground style home and turn it into
a de resort to escape the heat much like
we're doing now this is crazy now that
you've had a Fresno fact it's time for
our burrito fact actually incorrect
anaconda fact and why are we learning
about anacondas it's because we're about
to go eat the anaconda burrito at Taco
really Ellis it's why we're here taking
both weight and length into account
green anacondas are considered the
world's largest snakes they grow 20 to
30 feet long up to one foot in girth and
top out around 550 pounds that's a
minimum three Shaquille O'Neal's laying
down laying down yeah yeah and a foot in
girth that's like a basketball 20 feet
long to be ready at this burrito also
Adam is up there hi Anna
let's go we're on our way to Tucker
eager Ellis that's our last stop we're
gonna be meeting edwin there
[Music]
tell us about Tucker ei Oh Ellis my
parents decided to buy a taco stand
we were selling for about six years it
was real hard selling out on the street
at 2:00 in the morning it was dangerous
we actually got kicked out from selling
on the street the city kicked us out and
that was the last warning after that
we're gonna serve jail time my father
decided to open today at least it wasn't
going so good for about three years and
to anaconda burrito came up really
everybody here in frozen you know they
always had the same tacos burritos we
wanted to do it different he wanted to
have something that would have caught
everybody's attention
it was idea after idea we wanted to hit
the jackpot when we finally did how many
will actually order the Anaconda burrito
a lot you'd be surprised the day we get
about 50 to 70 on encounter burritos
really yep we're talking about two and a
half foot burritos so this is really
popular here in Fresno
it's real popular oh yeah it's real
popular so how do people find out about
the Anaconda burrito through a video
that I uploaded at the time I only had
about a thousand followers and that
video was uploaded and the next day I
wake up I had 150,000 followers
hello everybody sharing it and sharing
it all around the world do you think the
success of your restaurant is due in
part to the anaconda burrito oh yeah
definitely they bought us a house really
it bought us a house it's amazing with
anaconda burrito has done for us our
next step is opening a new location now
you're gonna be able to dine in do
bigger place right yeah and with AC yeah
AC is pretty key when you're eating a
two and a half foot for real oh yeah
[Music]
I think we can do this I have a lot of
confidence in us actually looking at it
now it's not dodging us hearing somebody
say two and half feet of burrito is this
even two and a half feet this feels
longer to me I'm glad you asked actually
I brought my protractor said firstly I
only have a six and a ruler so three
feet anaconda babies are born two feet
warm I think I can eat more of this than
you can where's the halfway point it's
right here okay it's right there I'm
gonna start at this end I think you
should start at that end okay oh-ho-ho
Wow it stays together boom you know good
breed huh
[Music]
once in middle school I got to hold a
big Python the weight is very similar to
like a large snake Steven got this ended
I think a back seat they'll sit in the
bench I've eaten a lot more than doing
this I'm already almost at the last four
via why you okay here's the center yeah
hey you're mine first
okay so that's good God brought you a
crazy watermelon thank you you're that
one is caught in the menu yep our crazy
water man so we get a water moment we
cut it in half
dice it we put it back in grab a mango
robbery's cucumbers and then we put the
special sauce which is a chamoy just put
I mean it's a Mexican at a war injury
fruit break yes okay I want
watermelon I'm ready to just have some
fruit chill a little bit we ready to
call it quits who won this is the center
point okay
I'm by a mile oh that was a big burrito
whoa
before we decide what our worth it
winners are we're going to stop into a
local brewery called Tioga Sequoia and
wash down that anaconda I got these
summer vibes papi Pilsner it's almost a
hundred degrees here in Fresno that's
what summer vibes I don't know what
summer vibes you got the Half Dome
California wheats two very peachy ranked
chairs well that's good which burrito
was the most worth it for you at his
given price all of the burritos I love
they all had their place and purpose but
my where the winner has to be Stan or a
town it's just so good that's my worth a
winner
Steven who's your with a winner thank
you for asking my worth that winner has
got to be the anaconda burrito it's a
worthy burrito it is it it's also an
insane value Adam who is you're worth it
winner
Annie who is you're worth it winner
here's to a great season six yeah
here's Adam
[Music]